pas situation elle est tendu tout
simplement déjà parce qu'effectivement
nous sommes toujours en vacances et donc
forcément les donneurs sont un petit peu
plus difficile à mobiliser
mais surtout ces dernières semaines nous
avons dû faire face à des sessions on va
dire des distributions de produits
sanguins importants et notamment dans
les groupes des le groupe le plus
important en martinique et le groupe o
est notamment le haut positif donc en ce
moment nous faisons un appel à tous les
donneurs et donneuses disponibles s'ils
peuvent dès ce week end et la semaine
prochaine venir donner alors bien sûr
tous les groupes sont importants mais
s'ils sont roux notamment ne pas hésiter
à venir donner parce qu'effectivement en
ce moment c'est difficile nos besoins
c'est toujours 60 dons par jour et
notamment un produit sur trois vient
encore de métropole donc je vais dire
qu'il ne faudrait en peu près 20 à 25
personnes supplémentaires tous les jours
pour venir donner donc ça n'arrivera pas
tout de suite ça va prendre du temps
mais nous sommes obligés notamment la
sur des périodes un petit peu critiques
comme celle ci est notamment avec des
tensions sur le haut et bien d'essayer
de mobiliser toute la population je
rappelle quand même que la solidarité
nationale c'est-à-dire que les autres
établissement français du sang qui nous
aident quand nous n'avons pas les
produits suffisant et bien là en ce
moment traverse aussi une période
particulière c'est les vacances mais
c'était aussi la canicule en france
hexagonale est donc plus que jamais
aujourd'hui ben martin qui est
martiniquaise nous devons mobiliser pour
assurer les besoins en produits sanguins
des vies sont en jeu tous les jours on
transfuse entre 3 6 4 sept personnes
tous les jours en martinique etc des
personnes qui peuvent continuer à vivre
que nous pouvons soigner grâce à votre
générosité
donc il faut il y aller et aujourd'hui
plus que puisque d'ordinaire